what can the fans of the first sharknado
expect with sharknado the second one
sharknado 2 the second one is basically
going to be bigger and better than the
first on the first one we made a
hundred-million-dollar film for less
than a million dollars and it shows you
know it's not let's not kid ourselves
about that at the same time I think the
fact that we were reaching for that is
part of what made it endearing on the
second one we're making a 200 million
dollar film on on again about 1% of the
money we should have but but by virtue
of the fact that it takes place in New
York and although we didn't think it at
the time the weather really helped us
because we were shooting a movie that
supposed to take place in the summer in
February in March of one of the worst
winters the east coast is seen in recent
memory and so we were cursing the
weather on a daily basis but it gave us
the look of an extreme weather pattern
that naturally a sharknado would bring
theirs so it's going to feel like a much
bigger better movie we knew the people
had taken to the first one in a certain
way and so we were able to guide the
second one to be what we thought they
would want it to be so it's not any more
tongue-in-cheek and it's not any more
serious than the first one we still walk
that same line but we reveled in the
sense of glee and fun that I think the
first one evoked and so anybody who
really liked the first one is going to
love the second one and the people who
hated the first one and who said it was
the worst movie ever made won't be able
to say that about the second one but I
think they'll still have fun interacting
with it the way they did the first one
do you have a message for the Twitter
people out there anything do you want to
convey I hope everybody on twitter just
has the same fun with this one that they
did with the first one and and I hope
they take it to their hearts because
that's that's why we're here if it
weren't for the folks on Twitter you
know we wouldn't be here doing this so
this this is a this is for you
you